I am just seeking advice for
being a 23 year old trying to figure out
life
um I just got accepted into a flight
flight attendant training program
um that I am gonna go do but I've kind
of done a jumble of things ever since
I've graduated college and I've had a
hard time really finding what it is that
I want to do like I've literally been a
teacher I've been a recruiter I've been
a bartender now I'm going to go be a
flight attendant so kind of the Jack of
all trades here but I guess just what's
your advice um when you guys were in
your 20s and how you kind of figured out
life and anything would help thanks guys
okay this is good I think it's uh an
unhelpful
myth basically that we should all find
what we're passionate about and do that
because that assumes everyone has a
passion but that is not
fair or Justified or that doesn't mirror
reality at all how many people do we all
know who who whose job is is is what
their passion is in life like that's
rare it happens but that's not common so
this idea that we're all supposed to
find what we're passionate about in life
and do that yeah if you're passionate
about something then try to do that that
makes sense but if you're like this nice
young woman and feeling this sort of
like pressure
from the outside in these external
pressure to like find out what your find
what you're passionate about and do that
she's like desperately looking for the
thing that she's passionate about
and can't find it so she keeps trying
this trying that trying not trying that
that's fine I mean you're 23 you're
young you do whatever you want for a
long time now you've got many years to
figure it out but
don't feel so much pressure to find a
thing that you're crazy passionate about
settle and I don't mean settle in life
like throw in the towel but settling for
something that you're good at that
provides you with the means to make a
living
is it's it's reward it will be rewarding
the rewards let's say are rewarding
enough to make that a worthwhile thing
to do in your life like
being a flight attendant it might not be
your passion but if you can get a good
position and you can make a ton of money
like that is a viable career because
then your success at it will lead to a
kind of happiness and your passions
like they should be for everybody for
most people your passions lie outside of
what you do for a living
like this is a misconception I think
people have all across the [__] world
passion
it look again if it ends up being that
you can pursue your passion while making
a living great but everybody feeling a
pressure to find what they're passionate
about before they settle into some
career good [__] luck and I'm not
being pessimistic I'm just saying this
is the [__] way it is find something
that you're good at that you can more
than tolerate and that will also pay you
and just do that and over time you will
build satisfaction and be proud of
yourself and you'll have money and thus
time to do things
that you're [__] passionate about
occupational passion
a maybe one out of the 30 people I know
one out of every 30 people I know
is passionate
at at work like that's it's not even
like a
think about it dude think about all the
people that you all know everyone
watching the show how many of them are
super passionate and fulfilled by their
job
that's not something that we should be
expecting in life it's great if it comes
along you're lucky as [__] if you get to
do it
but that is not even a realistic goal
for most people so
don't feel like you have to find
something that you're passionate about
don't be crushed by what the [__]
[__] uh cliche world is trying to
force down your throat it's not
realistic
and you should certainly not feel bad
about not finding your passion
at least when it comes to the workplace
um
yeah also just to come back to this real
quick your 20 she said she was 23 right
23 years old
I think so yeah that's so young
and I'm not saying like
I used to hate it when I was that age
and people would like tell me to slow
down or whatever because I wasn't where
I wanted to be in life in my career
whatever
but the reason everyone used to say that
to me is
a good one
because like you don't get those years
back once you turn like in your mid-30s
from that point on life is just like
basically the [__] same for everybody
where you are now it's full of
transition and mystery and potential and
doubt and excitement maybe passion but
like that
where you are now
to like maybe till you're 30. that's
like the meat of life just make sure you
live it don't be
too distracted by
this like carrot that is constantly
dangled in front of your face about
finding your passion and making a living
at it it's just not it's a [__] lie
like a lot of other things we were told
as kids but that is a [__] harmful
lie because there's a bunch of people
out there thinking oh I hate my life I
hate my job I wish I had something I was
passionate about
because it's like so [__] thick The
Ether
you're supposed to find your passion and
make money at it that's not a thing
really so don't feel bad if that's not
your thing
[Music]